All right, recapping the short. Today is
April 23rd.
Uh this one pretty much ticked every box
you'd want it to more or less in regards
to execution,
positioning and order flow, location
confluence, all that kind of stuff. So,
ultimately we capped this gray box in
older 4-day composite.
Ultimately we capped there. I took a
short there.
Uh we were put in this low passive offer
Sorry, passive bid stepped in here.
Ultimately we did bounce here.
Um but being that we did bounce here and
we front ran the single print of the gap
as well as weekly view up up to that
point, that also makes this more of a
target for me personally.
It's the way I was looking at it uh when
it came to actual confluence.
We have
the
4-day point of control. So, this older
4-day composite, the POC is there. So,
essentially it's an underside of retest
of that level.
Um and we have a what's going to be a
2-day composite what's currently
developing. If I reset this,
if I can, anyway.
Holy, what am I grabbing here?
If I reset it, this was yesterday and
then today obviously it is still
overlapping as it continues to develop,
but nonetheless 2 days of value.
So, essentially we built our value,
traded into val,
retested. We had an aggressive move back
up.
Uh it was also a golden pocket back test
there.
All right, so really easy
fib confluence to work with as well.
And ultimately it took out
uh took out these highs here.
It took out these highs into this
imbalance, underside retest of the 4-day
point of control. It's also essentially
a rotation back into weekly value high.
All right, so we were imbalanced up,
shifted back inside. This was a retest.
I think I took it initially on the first
short, maybe.
Was that it?
Oh, no, no, sorry. This was way up here.
But disregarding,
we shifted back into weekly value,
right? Putting this low, and then we get
another rotation up, another aggressive
spike into weekly value area high, and
then ultimately we traded down and
tagged the tagged the VWAP there. So,
um as for positioning and whatnot,
we had it was at the standard deviation
two on DVA,
and we had a lot of I think it was a big
squeeze here. So, I don't know, I guess
according to positioning here it was.
What do we got here?
I mean both really. We trapped buyers
here, and we ended up squeezing a lot of
shorts here, right? So, um you can see
the uptick there in
open interest, right? And then the
following candle, we can see longs start
to close.
And then ultimately this kind of chop
through it here, um buyers kind of
continued to try and push higher, right?
You can see open interest continues to
climb.
Um positive delta, and then ultimately
it led to this flip in the histogram
where we started to flush those longs,
right? So,
ultimately started to
um flip here, and then you can see open
interest just continues to puke lower.
I think it might even be easier seen on
the two-minute time frame. That's one
thing I do sometimes is I bounce to the
two-minute as well. I think the
one-minute is just noise, but the
two-minute sometimes gives better
clarity. So, I just kind of bounce
between them
when using this template. But,
nonetheless,
um yeah, trapped buyers up here at the
standard deviation two,
right? You can see that with the market
order bubbles here, um total delta up
here.
And then ultimately, yeah, it just
continued to climb. So, you can see it a
bit a bit better here, right? Open
interest continues to climb. Majority of
this is positive delta, and then
ultimately we break down, and uh upon
this move down, right? Open interest
starts to climb a little bit more, and
we start to flip the histogram into uh
to the negatives. So,
ultimately overall good trade.
I trimmed some at daily VWAP uh upon
this flush here,
and then trimmed the rest just at VAL,
and uh
just off a bounce off VAL in case we to
front run this lowest once more. I
wanted to secure that profit intraday,
so
overall um really good trade.